cela dit on a également évoqué la
sécurité sociale avec un rapport de
bernard pons rpr et puis avec un bilan
de la commission des comptes de la
sécurité sociale une commission
installée aujourd'hui par raymond barre
au ministère de la santé il faut dire
que la situation n'est guère brillante
on attendait un excédent de 4 milliards
de francs
on arrive en fin de compte un déficit de
2 milliards 4 pour la sécurité sociale
l'ordre dans l'énorme budget que
représente la sécurité sociale soit 100
milliards un déficit de 2 milliards et
demi s'est à peine un demi pour cent
il n'était pas prévu les dépenses de
maladie ont été plus forte qu'on ne le
pensait et les recettes un peu plus
faible mais ce déficit il faut le
combler les ressources dégagées en
décembre ne suffisent pas monsieur bart
annoncé ce matin des mesures on me
comprendra dans les semaines à venir un
certain nombre de mesures destinées à
infléchir de façon durable
l'évolution des dépenses la sécurité
sociale et notamment des dépenses de
santé l'objectif que nous poursuivrons
doit être clairement compris il faut
ramener le rythme de croissance des
dépenses à sécurité sociale au rythme de
croissance de la production nationale en
valeur à l'heure actuelle il existe un
décalage
un décalage qui va en s'aggravant un
décalage durable si nous ne réussissons
pas à atteindre l'objectif que je viens
de rappeler ce sera le système de
protection sociale des français qui sera
compromis freiner le rythme
d'accroissement des dépenses de santé
une orientation a déjà été prise et
consiste à passer au crible ce qui ne
paraît pas nécessaire en matière de
consommation médicale de médicaments et
à contrôler plus étroitement
l'équipement et la gestion des hôpitaux
tout fragile qu'il soit le système
français de sécurité sociale est l'un
des meilleurs du monde
le problème c'est de le sauvegarder cela
dit s'il ya des mesures à prendre et
cela paraît évident ce ne sera que pour
la fin juillet c'est à dire après le
remplacement de mme anne veille
au ministère de la santé